(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Para el proyecto, lanzamos 21 cohetes.
Esta animación lo muestra como una empresa sencilla, pero no lo fue.
Y actualmente tenemos más de 200 satélites en órbita
que transmiten datos a 31 estaciones terrestres construidas a tal fin.
En total, envían a diario 1500 millones de imágenes de la Tierra
con una resolución de 29 megapíxeles.
Y de cualquier sitio de la superficie terrestre
tenemos ahora un promedio de más de 500 imágenes.
Una gran recopilación de datos que documentan inmensos cambios.
Son muchos quienes usan estas imágenes.
Las empresas agrícolas las usan para mejorar el rendimiento de los cultivos;
las compañías que diseñan mapas, para mejorar los mapas de la web;
los gobiernos, para reforzar la seguridad en las fronteras
o para optimizar la ayuda luego de inundaciones, incendios y terremotos.
Y también las usan las ONG.
Por ejemplo, para rastrear y detener la deforestación,
ayudar en la búsqueda de refugiados que huyen de Myanmar,
o seguir los acontecimientos en la actual crisis de Siria,
haciendo responsables a todos los involucrados.
Y hoy, tengo el gusto de anunciar las historias de "Planet".
Cualquiera puede ingresar a planet.com,
abrir una cuenta y acceder a todas las imágenes en la web.
Se parece a Google Earth, solo que estas son imágenes actualizadas,
y además se pueden ver imágenes pasadas.
Se pueden comparar dos días al azar
y ver los drásticos cambios que ocurren en el planeta.
También se puede seleccionar un período que muestre a través de las 500 imágenes
los cambios producidos en ese tiempo.
Además, estos datos se pueden compartir en las redes sociales.
Es muy bueno.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
En un principio, estaba destinado a periodistas de noticias
que buscaban información objetiva de la actualidad.
Pero ahora cualquiera puede acceder, para uso personal, o sin fines de lucro.
Y esperamos que así la gente pueda ver los cambios que ocurren en el planeta
y actuar en consecuencia.
Pues bien, la gente cuenta ahora con estabase de datos sobre el planeta
que se actualiza todo el tiempo.
¿Cuál es nuestra próxima misión, la Misión 2?
En pocas palabras, es "espacio + IA".
Por medio de la inteligencia artificial,
buscamos objetos en todas las imágenes satelitales.
Las mismas herramientas de IA que se usan para buscar videos de gatos en la web
también pueden usarse para buscar información en nuestras imágenes.
Es decir, imaginemos que podemos identificar un barco, un árbol,
un auto, una carretera, un edificio, un camión.
Y si pudiéramos hacerlo con las millones de imágenes
que bajan por día,
se puede crear una base de datos
de todos los objetos medibles en el planeta, día tras día.
Y esa base de datos se puede buscar.
Es exactamente lo que estamos haciendo.
Vemos aquí un prototipo, donde usamos nuestra API.
Esto es Beijing.
Supongamos que queremos contar los aviones de un aeropuerto.
Seleccionamos el aeropuerto
y el programa busca los aviones entre las imágenes de hoy
y también los aviones de imágenes anteriores,
y luego crea este gráfico de todos los aviones del aeropuerto de Beijing
en una línea temporal.
Obviamente, esto se puede hacer con todos los aeropuertos del mundo.
Vayamos ahora al puerto de Vancouver.
Haríamos lo mismo, pero con embarcaciones.
Ampliamos la imagen de Vancouver, seleccionamos el área,
buscamos las embarcaciones
y aparece un gráfico que muestra dónde están las naves.
Pensemos cuán útil sería esto para la guardia costera
que intenta rastrear y detener la pesca ilegal.
Los barcos pesqueros legales
comunican su posición mediante el sistema de identificación automática,
pero no todas las embarcaciones lo hacen.
Las imágenes no mienten.
Así, la guardia costera puede usar este sistema
para detectar barcos de pesca ilegal.
Y en breve, además de barcos y aviones, podremos incorporar otros objetos
y así transmitir datos sobre la posición de todos estos objetos en el tiempo
y pueden ser integrados digitalmente a las tareas del usuario.
Con el tiempo, podremos usar buscadores más sofisticados
que la gente puede obtener de distintas fuentes.
Y finalmente, imagino que podríamos extraer todas las imágenes
y hacer una interfaz interactiva con la Tierra.
Imaginemos si pudiéramos preguntar: "¿cuántas casas hay en Pakistán?
Quiero un mapeo a través del tiempo".
"¿Cuántos árboles hay en el Amazonas
y en qué sitios se talaron árboles entre esta semana y la anterior?"
¿No sería maravilloso?
Pues bien, es lo que queremos lograr,
sería como una Tierra "interactiva".
En resumen, la Misión "Planet" 1 fue tomar imágenes diarias del planeta
y hacerlas accesibles.
La Misión "Planet" 2 es indexar todos los objetos del planeta en el tiempo
y hacerlo interactivo.
Terminaré con una analogía.
Google indexó la información en Internet y la hizo de acceso público.
Pues bien, nosotros estamos haciendo lo mismo
con la información de la Tierra.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)